el bahri bonsoir bonsoir
mareva galanter et nu à côté de moi
j'allais voir je vais vivre ce que linda
hardy a vécu ce qu'elle m'a raconté
tellement de choses moi je veux savoir
si c'est vrai donc je crois qu est ce
que vous a dit qu'est ce que vous a dit
non je vous dirai après après
bien pâle bonsoir mais c'est tout le
monde alors aujourd'hui paul barril vous
êtes expert en sécurité
et chasseurs de terroristes en afrique
et dans les pays arabes a visité à la
tête du groupe baril sécurité c'est ça
non la protection du renseignement une
intelligence économique
ouais et de la protection
vous habitez ou
dans le monde entier ah ouais le monde
est vaste et il y a beaucoup de demandes
que ce soit des chefs d'état des
particuliers
vous voyez la sécurité glisse de partout
tous les jours vous voyez en afrique il
ya des coups d'état vous voyez des
français enlevé des étrangers
tout le monde ceux qui le demandent et
mais les pays
c'est lui
kpn l'homme et dames et messieurs alors
dites moi donc je vivais dans une espèce
de semi clandestinité on est discret
dans ce métier il vaut mieux essayer
vous n'êtes pas que des amis un poulain
et heureusement bah ouais parce que je
prends un exemple de votre famille
question prouteau il dit en parlant de
vous baril c'est un mensonge par jour
mais c'est pas lui qui le dit mais n'a
jamais dit en phase avec envoyée j'ose
pas vous le dire en fait j'aurais bien
aimé qu'il soit là oui moi je dirais pas
du mal et la nuit lui visé il est là
comme joue introduction trop tôt
bien pourquoi ressasser les proto et
alors vous savez c'est broussard du
parler local le père sa pipe il vous
arrive est celui de mende où il vous en
veux broussard je vous dire pourquoi ils
nous envient broussard parce que dans
votre premier livre vous le reprocher de
s'être attribué le succès du gign et
aujourd'hui quand il parle de vous
broussard ai dit vous êtes un peu le 007
et la petite semaine
pareil c'est j'aimerais bien qu'il
vienne me le dire en face
allez
oh
les beaux cheveux pendant ledit nyanda
elle veut jouer bien donc aujourd'hui
vous publiez votre troisième livre qui
s'appelle l' enquête explosive je mesure
mes garçons
et l'autre la
garantie sociale bien sûr savoir ya
quelqu'un qui s'appelle yann shermag qui
m'ont bien dit m me disant est ce que
chez soi on doit secouer les mains comme
ça bien sûr que oui j'étais pas mal
enquête explosive yan tu es bête
qui commet une boulette enfin bon moi
l'anc est explosif le baril donc vous
nous raconter un petit peu le thème
l'histoire commence dans ce qu'on
appelle les lie à quatre places en
afrique c'est quoi les lie à quatre
places vous savez en afrique je crois
qu'on a une vie qui est beaucoup plus
près de beaucoup plus sensuelle qui est
beaucoup plus près de la nature et qui
est beaucoup plus près de ce congrès
avant fin mai et le soir en afrique dans
les grands hôtels ou autre chose il ya
des jeunes filles qui tape aux portes et
on dit qu'est ce que c'est et on entend
la réponse qui est partout c'est l'amour
qui passe oh là là
vous ne faites rêver là la cause donc
j'ai dit à quatre places et ça ça
commence à l'hôtel ivoire donc dans un
avis à quatre places et votre votre
récit commence autour d'une somptueuse
quinquas qui s'appelle marie thérèse
houphouët boigny qu'elle épouse du
président houphouët boigny lui est
centenaire et est courtisé par un apolit
un aux yeux de braise à un peu louche
qui s'appelle hugo qui a été condamné en
france à 15 ans de prison pour rap et
rapt dans une affaire qui est qui était
célèbre sega faire du pdg a attendu 16
ans et phonogrammes ouais il faut savoir
que la la sphère judiciaire s'est
terminée cette année avec les assises de
la dernière personne qui a été condamné
à dire en riant 2000 au parler de la
françafrique on disait tout à l'heure ça
vous connaissez bien vous
la françafrique en tant que mise la
coopération la françafrique c'est l'
influence de la france en afrique qui
malgré la décolonisation et puis ils ont
voulu partir pour les france afrique
françafrique voit
comme la france
intervient quand intervient ça te ce
passage là bas
mais moi je suis invitée sur l'émission
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un français afrique mercenaires
barberousse gangster extrême droite bon
voilà quoi et non mais également je
crois qu'il faudrait
actuellement en afrique il ya quand même
une guerre mondiale qui est en train de
se passer il ya neuf pays qui sont en
guerre
le professeur et qui était ministre de
la coopération peut vous le dire aussi
il ya peut-être eu trois millions de
morts en deux ou trois ans et on encore
une part qui demande et vous avez vu il
ya quelques temps là le livre mission
explosifs se passe à abidjan vous avez
suivi les images qui ont été donnés de
l'élection présidentielle entre d'ivoire
où il ya eu des charniers qui ont été
découverts comme en yougoslavie et où on
a un chef d'état qui a été poussé par
les hommes politiques français qui est
aujourd'hui président de la république
en côte d'ivoire avec pas 20 % des voix
dites-moi qui a des bons jours à paris
je voyais déjà
ces
experts il est question de mairie le
fameux mairie la cassette méry et vous
dites dans vsd cette semaine c'est très
important ça vous dit moi j'ai deux les
journalistes nota ne s'intéressent pas
assez aux morts par cancer vous pensez
que mary été tués je pense qu'il ya des
disparation qui arrange beaucoup
d'hommes politiques parce que quand on
ferme quand il ya quelqu'un qui décède
on peut mourir d'un cancer le cancer un
professeur peut le dire peut être
accéléré je peux dire non plus que la
revenir aux gens ce qu'ils disent est
important il laisse en tant que
finalement et je vais jamais y aura été
un peu comment on peut le faire on peut
bien à déclencher un cancer qui est une
sorte de leucémie en mettant des
substances radioactives ou de la poudre
sur le siège etc ou sous votre lit et
pendant deux mois quand vous absorbez
des quantités comme ça qu'il ya eu
résultat d'un pôle est on non
ça c'est la méthode moderne et c'est
comme ça que ça se passe il ya plein de
services qui on faisait des preuves sur
sur mairie des indices graves et
concordants part donc dans le livre là
on voit que les fausses factures sont
parties jusqu'à abidjan il ya une
commission rogatoire les gens gars
financières sont allés à abidjan mais la
personne non retour et est décédé fin du
dossier judiciaire au mythe du rhin
attendons la prochaine cassette non mais
moi c'est moi je le suis formidable avec
en général les flics les souffles hic
est super flic et tous ceux qui sont de
cette catégorie la très nécessaire dans
un certain nombre de cas c'est qu'autant
vous n'êtes pas capables de voir qu'il
ya un certain nombre de dictatures dans
le monde autant la france qui est un
pays démocratique qui bien entendu a
connu des affaires comme celle que vous
dites mais dans l'ensemble j'ai plutôt
tendance à faire confiance à ce pays
qu'à d'autres et quand vous évoquez la
sphère mairie sous cet angle là j'ai
l'impression si vous n'avez pas de
preuve que vraiment vous devriez vous
taire parce que c'est pas possible de
laisser entendre qu'un homme a été
assassiné si vous n'apportez pas là le
début d'un début de recherche
bon alors paul barril maintenant
sérieusement est-ce que vous avez un
mime et micro preuve que jean-pierre
mairie aurait pu être assassiné
ou est ce que c'est une vous dites il
aurait pu être assassiné ou ce que vous
avez un début de quelque chose vous
savez on n'a pas besoin de forcément
d'une preuve là la preuve la reine de la
preuve c'est l'aveu de la propre
personne mais on a des indices graves et
concordants et vous savez danger le
système judiciaire français par exemple
les assises il n'y a pas besoin de
preuve il suffit que les gens sont
convaincus il suffit que les personnes
qui sont derrière qui vont juger il
suffit qu'ils assez d'éléments pour
qu'ils soient convaincus est qu'il donne
vingt ans de prison à la personne qui
est qu'ils ont à juger
biblique canton juste quelqu'un aux
assises souvent faute de preuves on se
contente de composition du jury et c'est
les indices graves et concordants il
fait des propositions juge le non mais
les temps d'audition une question moi je
veux même pas en juge on dit voilà il ya
des éléments mais monsieur baril sur
yoplait monsieur bédié allié des cas la
ferme et ris
ce qu'elle gêne le plus c'est le rpr
donc quand vous évoquez c'est le rpr et
ne nous ont pas autour du pot c'est le
rpr et c'est le président de la
république quand vous évoquez la
possibilité que monsieur mairie était
assassiné indirectement vous évoquez le
fait que le rpr ou des gens liés au rpr
et pu le tuer ce que je trouve
invraisemblable notre santé
soit qu'elle va rester bien oui
catherine et katherine me dit elie veut
absolument réagir et agissez parce que
maintenant qu'elle l'a dit non je
voulais dire simplement dans cette caste
qui a nié chose il ya des choses qui
sont contre
ok
donc but mairie n'est pas mort de mort
naturelle il faut attendre encore sa
mort a bien arrangé tout
lui même il ya tellement redouté qui a
enregistré à cassettes et il a donné des
instructions que après sa mort il ya qu
à 7 soit diffusé c'est quand même ils se
savent bien danger et il a été à
nombreuses personnes et à des
journalistes à dire en cas de
disparition voilà ce que je lègue c'est
une bombardiers allemands alors que le
baril vous êtes fils petit fils de
gendarme et fait saint cyr en 75 avec
votre ami christian proto vous montez le
gign
george iny gène intervient à djibouti la
libération du quart d'enfants a pris en
otage à la mecque neutralisation de
terroristes intégristes
opération anti indépendantistes en corse
et ensuite vous devenez de plus en plus
lié avec le pouvoir et vous occuper de
la cellule antiterroriste de l'elysée
vous devenez un petit peu la garde
prétorienne de françois mitterrand ce
qu'on appelle les gendarmes de l'elysée
alors la sphère des irlandais de
vincennes
c'est quand même autre grosse affaire on
vous soupçonne d'avoir déposé des armes
et des munitions dans un appartement
suspect avant d'aller perquisitionner
et ce n'est toujours pas réglé la faire
non alors bon vous êtes trop puissant
pour qu'elle puisse se régler
au niveau juridique je voudrais vous
dire quand même peu de choses il ya une
instruction qui en cours moi m'a jamais
rien demandé je n'ai pas écrit trois
lignes vu un jeu sans indices
concordants
encore vous aime
je
suis sélectionneur c'est normal il reste
un contentieux de 68 mais j'arrive à le
comprendre et pour en revenir à une
chose ou est d'accord il n'y a pas de
petits ou grands terroristes un
terroriste qui est sa définition
c'est quelqu'un qui abandonne
l'ordinateur ou le stylo pour jouer avec
des explosifs et des armes ou on est du
côté des salopards ou on est du côté des
gens biens et de la démo que voulait
dire que le baril si on comprend bien se
dire que les irlandais de vincennes
pl inquiète et ses copains finalement
vous vous dites aujourd'hui bon ce n'est
peut-être pas des méchants terroristes
mais on a bien fait de les serrer parce
qu'on est des terroristes qu'on soit
petit ou grand c'est pareil je voudrais
dire deux mots sa rentrée sur le fond le
terrorisme irlandais quels qu'ils soient
l'ira ou l'inra c'est 3000 morts en dix
ans en europe n'oubliez jamais ça 3000
morts en dix dents et pour ces gens là
ont du sang sur les mains et si vous me
demandiez si on devait refaire
l'opération je dirai ce qu'ils ont fait
l'opération avec moi on l'a fait sur
orne on l'a bien fait on a empêché que
le sang coule peut-être le vote donc
vous regardiez
vraiment pour les les gens plus jeunes
qui ne connaissent pas cette affaire la
question des pôles du tout savoir les
questions délire du temps de savoir s'il
ira et criminel ou pas la question c'est
de savoir si pour coincer ces gens là on
a fabriqué des preuves où sont vos
preuves si vous m'avez vu tout à l'heure
il n'a même pas des indices graves et
concordants voyez vous c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu une c'est pour ça qu'il ya
eu une enquête de la justice mais
écoutez ya même pas une porte d'enfance
et subit une claque par contre je vous
demanderais puisse vous être bien
informé demandez aux anglais pourquoi
les anglais ont décoré les français qui
ont fait cette opération elle en est si
vous supportez et si vous êtes du côté
des gens qui mettent des bombes
peut-être dans des grandes sociétés ou
des trucs comme ça vous êtes de l'autre
côté si vous êtes de l'autre côté vous
êtes ce que vous dites que le baril
aujourd'hui c'est seule la fin justifie
les moyens c'est à dire que même si ces
irlandais était pas vraiment ce jour-là
dangereux le fait d'avoir apporté des
armes chez eux pour les séries
finalement c'est pour la bonne cause et
je voudrais vous dire une chose c'est
que une des dames qui était dedans
goss quelques années plus tard elle m'a
remercié el mahdi grâce à vous
aujourd'hui je suis encore en vie voyez
et au terrorisme et à le piège vous
voyez ce qui se passe entre nous vous
reconnaissez quand même temps je
reconnais rien jamais 1 comme virenque
jamais c'est comme biarritz changé je
voudrais conclure religieux devait
refaire je referais la même opération
avec les mêmes personnes dans les mêmes
conditions on a évité que le sang coule
et je crois qu'il ya que ça qui importe
donc c'est une façon de reconnaître un
petit peu quand même nous que je ferais
pareil pour le bien de tout le monde
peut-être pour le vôtre aussi non mais
moi je vous écoute avec vraiment
beaucoup d'intérêt parce que je veux que
vous puissiez dire lorsqu'on évoque la
démocratie la justice le fait qu'on ne
peut pas poursuivre des gens sans preuve
que vous me disiez alors du coup vous
êtes du côté du terrorisme ça me fait
penser aux gens qui torturait en algérie
et qui disait c'est pour empêcher les
attentats de se commettre on peut être
démocrate on peut haïr les terroristes
on peut détester les bombes comme c'est
mon cas et en même temps souhaité que
dans une démocratie chaque fois qu on
coince des gens c'est avec des preuves
c'est pas antinomiques et je trouve que
c'est pas juste de dire qu'on est du
côté du terrorisme lorsqu'on dit
simplement à jc selon les règles du
droit bernard debré vous est ce à dire
que les siens se côtoient j'avais que
vous en pensez de sa sphère des
irlandais de vincennes
moi je pense que 1000 r un peu raison
parce que si on commence à dire que on
va fabriquer des preuves je n'en sais
rien attendait le n'aggravez pas votre
garde à vue enfants
je serai pas le premier politique non
mais c'est pas c'est que moi je reviens
pas je ferai une manifestation libérer
des aubrais première ville wahlbeck à
gaza serait formidable vient alors la
cellule antiterroriste de l'elysée il ya
eu des écoutes assez l'époque on
écoutait carole bouquet jean yanne
alliés est ce qu'aujourd'hui encore des
écoutes téléphoniques en france 4000
4010 en principe les journaliers ceux
qui font des émissions un peu engagés
tout ce qui touche aux aussi écoute moi
tout ce qui touche par exemple au
dossier vers il ya des millions de
personnes
il y avait aussi les téléphones et
écoutés par exemple sérieusement je
pense ça doit être intéressant parce que
vous avez des contacts non mais c'est
bien quand même on n'écoute pas
quelqu'un pour forcément lui faire du
mal non on nique on écoute quelqu'un en
numéro de son dealer non non pour savoir
quels sont ses contacts politiques qui
ce qui lui donne des conseils reçoit un
tat l'émission est sûre c'est sûr et ça
donne du renseignement d'ambiance et du
renseignement politique vous qu'on
s'était muni de la coopération
j'étais écoutez moi non mais vous allez
vous avez eu accès à des diffusions mais
si comme tous les ministres dites le
vous avez un quota vous avez accès
réponse spéciaux aussi et tout le monde
sait moins c'est pas vrai il découvre
tintin sera aussi bernard oui fonds
spéciaux pas fonds spéciaux qui lever
des fonds si on sauve et et surtout soit
une opération avec l'afrique sont votés
par l'assemblée 500 millions par an 50
milliards si oui mais on sait pas où ça
passe et on n'est pas obligé de rendre
la comptabilité est une comptabilité
caille été brûlé une fois par an
matignon non mais c'est vrai c'est
faible et ça existe depuis toujours il
ya c'est pas pour ça que c'est une bonne
chose a
bien donc sur les écoutes vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui ça continue je c'est pas
je pense c'est une institution d'état ça
s'appelle le gic il ya 4000 écoute on
écoute les téléphones portables on
écoute les facs et on fait des écoutes
thématiques par exemple tout très email
personnel c'est une très très facile au
contraire que si à l'informatique plus
il ya du téléphone portable et il ya des
logiciels qui traite aujourd'hui pas
forcément les coûteuses mais masquer les
difficultés ce démo serait un remake
mais iront dire connaissant mais le
nombre de téléphones par exemple on vous
fait le hit parade sur le mois les trois
numéros que vous appelez le plus combien
dure la conversation ici c'est vous qui
appelez ou si c'est la personne qui vous
appelle et à partir de ça on arrive à
faire une toile d'araignée on vous met
au milieu vous en sortez plus et bien la
violence il ya un vieux blancs là on va
bien dormir ce soir on va pas appeler
soirée bien je vais remonter comme vous
êtes un homme de coups on va vous faire
une interview dans le rouge pendant les
guignols
[Musique]
votre dernier coup dur paul barril tous
les jours aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on va
maintenant voilà les irlandais de
vincennes vingt ans après un pas une
claque pas une forme de cachets une
affaire internationale vraiment on se
demande pourquoi on vous le reproche un
manga regard est cet homme un mec même
pas amener les armes chez moi j'ai eu un
peu peur quand il a dit votre dernier
coup dur et qui m'a montré
heureusement qu'elle était moins me
dernier coup de tête paul
peut-être le livre est pas mal
le dernier coup de coeur le rwanda
pourquoi parce que c'est un c'est un
pays qui voue d'abord il ya eu 3
millions de morts je pense en quelques
temps et ça a été la plus grande
manipulation historique où on a fait
croire qu'un qu'une ethnie avaient
massacré une autre ethnie alors s non
celle inverse dans les coups de poing la
semaine dernière avec qui le soir donc
ça c'est une affaire père privé voilà
c'est à dire leur demander encore non
non non c'est mieux non il me regardait
pas quand vous parlez de coups de poing
des coups de tête ils m'inquiètent
capitaine dernier coup de foudre
dernier coup de foudre
c'est difficile simple vous avez avec
votre non pas deux derniers coups de feu
non non
je voulais pas le dire non c'est normal
ça se garde un
dernier coup de gueule
il ya une semaine avant le coup d'envoi
non non avec mon équipe ce soir un
problème africain et une mission à
l'extérieur mais ce que je crois que
quand on a on est manager dans le privé
on a une organisation civile mais quand
même à caractère militaire et le chef il
garde une vieille notion peut-être ça
c'est important pour vous qui vouliez
greffer des choses pour moi le chef
c'est celui qui crie le plus fort qui
frappe le plus fort et c'est celui qui
se fait respecter non mais ça va avec le
côté également intellectuelle mais sur
le terrain ça se passe comme ça ma mère
me l'air ça je suis sûr
mais non mais je pense c'est pour vous
at on déjà pour vous baril s'est
agi story je voudrais vous dire aussi
baril si je voudrais vous dire quand
même que le courage moral beaucoup
d'hommes politiques que l'on mais moi le
courage moral va avec le courage
physique 1 et certains ont beaucoup de
courage moral mais de courage physique
il n'y a pas grand chose ça pète et sega
ou de vous devez intervenir vous devez
greffer une puce de téléphone et que
beaucoup les échos un pentium de courage
physique est ce que je sais un autre
monde je pourrais simplement diane ne
sait pas c'est que c'est un personnage
historique
mais ce qui était un personnage
historique je trouve que je ne doute pas
de votre courage physique puisque je
connais un petit peu quand même votre
carrière mais vous avez le sans doute
l'âge venant intégrer de du maintien de
l'ordre tout ce qu'il ya de pire c'est
pas la seule chose de bien intégrer
c'est à dire l'idée est justement de la
force appliquée la loi l'idée que grosso
modo vous êtes là en position de
supérieur c'est non pas du tout quoi non
je voudrais voir une chaudrée mort-né
nombreux il ya des dames qui sont ici le
premier problème qu'est ce que vous
voulez tous vous voulez tous cas
sécurité voulaient sortir tranquille
vous voulez vivre tranquillement vous
aimez pas la sécurité vous avez retrouvé
votre voiture le terrifiant vous pouvez
arrive heureusement que message
politique mais tout le monde veut ça
aujourd'hui mais 20 à quel prix on peut
d'abord l'on veut laisser en moulinant
menacé en sortant ce soir 20h et eric
emboutir votre portefeuille vous allez
dire merci non j'appellerais la police
dans sept métiers vous appelez quitte
plus les pieds longtemps douleur et la
police républicaine qui a aussi des jo
d'hiver de voir monsieur barry et je
trouve terrible et
cela t'intéresse ces discussions là
on a besoin non mais je trouve ça
formidable je croyais qu aujourd'hui la
police était définitivement républicaine
qu'elle comprenait que pour faire
appliquer la loi il faut l'appliquer à
soi-même monsieur barry vous n'avez pas
changé depuis 1968 je t'aime à voir avec
les pavés est en train de mettre le feu
aux voitures alors que nous on veut des
campagnes tranquille on veut que les
enfants aillent à l'école on veut qu'ils
aient pas de pédophiles n'ont pu ni sur
les réseaux internet et c'est ce que
demandent tous les gens bien et coup de
rouge
ou de rejet année coup de rouge qui
comprend pas question que de rouge ouais
je bois pas je ne fume pas jamais bu
jamais fumé avant c'est comme ça alors
mes chers bien servir
dernier coup de bluff rbia y monte mais
c'est terrible je fais des coups de
fusil
secret défense dans les coups de blues
ea n'a pas jamais de coup de blues non
c'est formidable jacques nom des gens
quand jamais de coup de blues c'est pas
moi je peux pas répondre là parce que
chaque fois
[Applaudissements]
le fait d'être fliqué sans arrêt comme
ça moi je trouve ça insupportable
j'aime pas la police quoi moi
c'est comme ça c'est un habit ses fans
avides you parce que j'aime j'aime pas
non plus les gangsters j'aime pas non
plus les mafiosi génial en plus de ça
mais y'a un moment donné où il ya
collision qu'il ya collusion plutôt que
collision il ya collision avec moi en
tout cas j'ai jamais pu appeler les
flics quand j'avais à régler un problème
j'ai été voir le mec j'ai parlé si
c'était vraiment grave ils sont jamais
déplacés jamais et la fois que je me
suis trouvé dans des commissariats en
garde à vue où tout j'ai vu des choses
atroces et dégueulasse mais profondément
sous le coup de la loi avec des gens qui
étaient sous le couvert de l'ordre de
leurs képis ray des tas de choses
humiliantes profondément salle quand on
était avec l'histoire du dal il y avait
50 cars de flics pas des gens comme vous
pas des les gendarmes correct d'accord
poli propre sur eux et on les paye c'est
nous qui les payons quoi et un moment
donné j'ai demandé un flic quand j'étais
en garde à vue jeudi mais vous n'êtes
pas gardiens de la paix une non monsieur
je suis fonctionnaire de police attend
c'est quoi ça gardiens de la paix pour
moi ça voulait dire quelque chose mais
fonctionnaires de police va te faire
voir va te faire voir
dernière question paul barril dernier
coup de rein
et reçoit soldats et enquête explosive
merci au revoir
et cela m'a
merci donc au capitaine
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus